♪ ♪
>> Jesse: THAT DIDN’T TAKE
LONG.
DEMOCRATS ARE NOW DEMANDING A
NEW WAVE OF INVESTIGATIONS INTO
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
IT COMES AFTER SENIOR DOJ
OFFICIALS OVERRULED THE
SENTENCING RECOMMENDATION TO
SEND ROGER STONE TO JAIL FOR
OVER NINE YEARS.
FOUR OF THE PROSECUTORS ON THE
CASE QUIT IN PROTEST AND
DEMOCRATS SAY TRUMP INTERFERED
BY TWEETING ABOUT IT.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT SAYS THE
DECISION WAS MADE BEFORE TRUMP
TOOK TO TWITTER AND THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA OF COURSE IS
LOSING IT.
SPEAK OF THIS IS WHAT A
BANANA REPUBLIC DOES.
THIS IS WHAT A DICTATOR DOES.
IF YOUR FRIEND OF TRUMP, GO OUT
AND ROB A BANK BECAUSE HE’S GOT
YOU COVERED.
>> IT’S PREPOSTEROUS TO THINK
THE PRESIDENT’S OWN PUBLIC
STATEMENTS HAD NO IMPACT.
>> I’VE NEVER SEEN THIS HAPPEN
IN MY ENTIRE CAREER.
>> WILL DONALD TRUMP NOT DO
WHATEVER HE COULD DO IF HE COULD
GET AWAY WITH IT WAS MARK IF HE
COULD ARREST EVERY JOURNALIST HE
DIDN’T LIKE, DO YOU THINK HE
WOULD ARREST US ALL TO MARK WAS
MARK IF YOU THINK HE WOULDN’T,
YOU’RE LYING TO YOURSELF.
>> Jesse: PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
FIRED UP.
SPEAK OF FACT THAT ROGER STONE
WAS TREATED HORRIBLY IN THEIR
LIVES WERE DESTROYED.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
THEY SAW THE HORRIBLENESS OF A
NINE YEAR SENTENCE FOR DOING
NOTHING.
YOU HAVE MURDERERS AND DRUG
ADDICTS DON’T GET NINE YEARS.
MEANWHILE, JIM COMEY MAKES BOOK
DEALS, THE PEOPLE THAT LAUNCHED
THE SCAM INVESTIGATION AND WHAT
THEY DID WAS A DISGRACE.
>> Jesse: DO YOU WANT IS SEE
ROGER STONE FOR NINE YEARS?
NINE YEARS AS A DEATH SENTENCE
FOR SOMEONE LIKE THAT.
HE IS LIKE 70 YEARS OLD.
>> Greg: A YEAR WOULD BE FOR
ME.
>> Jesse: YOU FOR A WEEK.
>> Greg: I MIGHT ENJOY, YOU
NEVER KNOW.
YOU DON’T HAVE TO GO ANYWHERE.
>> Dana: THERE IS NO RED WINE
THERE.
>> Juan: WAIT A SECOND.
ALL RIGHT, ANYWAY, FOUR CAREER
PROSECUTORS, I DON’T THINK
THERE’S ANY QUESTION SOMETHING
BAD IS GOING ON HERE WITH REGARD
TO A PILLAR OF OUR GREAT
AMERICAN CONSTITUTION, WHICH IS
THAT WE ARE A NATION OF LAWS AND
SUDDENLY YOU HAVE THE
PRESIDENT -- YOU KNOW WHAT
STRUCK ME TODAY?
I REMEMBER WHEN THIS PRESIDENT
GOT UPSET BECAUSE BILL CLINTON
MET WITH LORETTA LYNCH AND HE
SAID, OH, MY GOD, HE WAS
INFLUENCING THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
TO DO HIS BIDDING WITH REGARD TO
HILLARY AND THE EMAILS.
NOW HERE COMES PRESIDENT TRUMP,
AND HE IS CLEARLY EXPRESSING HIS
VIEWS IN A WAY THAT WILL
INFLUENCE THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
BILL BARR TO COME OUT AND SAY,
OH, YEAH, YOU KNOW THESE
PROSECUTORS OF MINE, THEY HAVE
OVERDONE IT.
BUT THAT IS CORRUPTION.
THIS IS UNBELIEVABLE.
TO BE ON THE PRESIDENT CAN’T
EXPRESS HIS VIEWS ON TWITTER?
I GUESS THAT IS ANOTHER
IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE.
>> Katie: I MADE SOME PHONE
CALLS TODAY TO TRY TO CLARIFY
WHAT IS GOING ON AT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT AND HOW THIS WHOLE
THING WENT DOWN HERE THE
TIMELINE HERE IS VERY IMPORTANT.
THE DOJ WAS IN CONTACT WITH THE
ATTORNEY FOR A WEEK ABOUT THIS
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
PROSECUTORS WOULD GO TO THE
JUDGE AND SAY WE ARE GOING TO
RECOMMEND LESS THAN SEVEN TO
NINE YEARS.
SEVEN TO NINE IS TOO HARSH BUT
WE ARE NOT GOING TO SAY IN
NUMBER.
THEY GO IN, THEY WERE OF THE
U.S. ATTORNEY IN D.C., FIRST
WEEK ON THE JOB AND THEY SAY
SEVEN TO NINE YEARS.
BILL BARR FINDS OUT ABOUT IT,
IT’S A TOTAL DISASTER AND THEY
SAY NOW WE HAVE TO CHANGE IT
BECAUSE IT’S NOT FAIR AND IT
DOESN’T ACTUALLY MATCH WHAT WENT
DOWN WITH THE TRIAL.
SO THAT DECISION WAS MADE, THERE
WAS AN UNDERSTANDING A WEEK
BEFORE THIS HAPPENED.
THEN TRUMP DECIDES TO GO ON
TWITTER AND DISCUSS IT,
WHICH CREATED ALL THIS BACKLASH
ABOUT DOES HE HAVE INFLUENCE.
BUT THEY’VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
THIS AND WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE FOR MORE
THAN A WEEK WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT THIS FILING
AND SENTENCING WOULD BE LESS, OR
AT LEAST NOT SEVEN TO NINE YEARS
FOR ROGER STONE.
IN THE U.S. ATTORNEY’S OFFICE
ESSENTIALLY BLEW IT AND NOW YOU
HAVE THESE MUELLER PROSECUTORS
SAYING, WE ARE OUT.
BUT THE REASONS WHY IN THE
TIMELINE IS GETTING A LITTLE BIT
MIXED UP WITH PEOPLE WHO ARE
TALKING ABOUT IT.
>> Jesse: WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> Greg: I AM NO LONGER GOING
TO GIVE THE MEDIA OR THE
DEMOCRATS ANY ADVICE.
I’M NO LONGER GOING TO TELL THEM
THE SMART THING TO DO BECAUSE I
DID THAT WITH OBSTRUCTION AND
COLLUSION AND BRETT KAVANAUGH
AND IMPEACHMENT, THEY IGNORE IT.
SOME GOING TO SAY TO THE MEDIA,
"MORNING JOE" AND TO CNN, CHASE
THIS STORY!
GO FOR, HAVE ADDED!
THIS IS GOING TO WIN AMERICAN
MINDS.
IF YOU GET SOME GUY TO DIE IN
JAIL.
IT’S IRONIC THAT TRUMP IS
GETTING PEOPLE OUT OF PRISON AND
ALL THE DEMS WANT TO DO IS KEEP
THROWING PEOPLE BACK IN.
THESE ARE ALL THE FILTERS THEY
HAVE, YOU WATCH "THE VIEW."
, THEY ARE IN A CONSTANT STATE
OF PAIN AND "MORNING JOE" WAKES
UP EVERY MORNING IN A HISSY FIT
BECAUSE THEIR FILTER IS
DEFECTIVE IN THE KEEP SEEING
THESE THINGS AS THE END OF THE
WORLD.
YOU MISSED THE BIG STORY IS PURE
JEFFREY EPSTEIN, THEY
MISSED JUST A SMALL ACT.
THIS IS IT,
SOMETHING THIS IS GOING TO WIN
THE PULITZER, CHASE THIS STORY,
YOU GOT TO GET ROGER STONE IN
JAIL FOR LIFE.
THAT IS GREAT, GO FOR IT.
>> Jesse: RAPISTS SPENT FOUR
YEARS IN PRISON AND THIS GUY
GOES NINE YEARS BECAUSE
JOHN PODESTA SENT A PHISHING
EMAIL TO RUSH A CUSTOMER CAN THE
GUY WHO WAS SUPPOSEDLY
INTIMIDATED SAYS, I WASN’T
INTIMIDATED.
>> I THINK WHAT WILL END UP
HAPPENING, THE ASSISTANT U.S.
ATTORNEY’S RESIGN, THEY WILL
ALSO BE INVESTIGATED, THEY WERE
WITHHOLDING INFORMATION FROM THE
U.S. ATTORNEY, SO NOW THEY’RE
GOING TO HAVE ANOTHER SIX WEEKS
OR SO BECAUSE BILL BARR HAS
AGREED TO TESTIFY IN FRONT OF
CONGRESS ON MARCH 31ST.
WE’VE SEEN HOW THAT HAS GONE, HE
RUNS RINGS AROUND THEM BUT MARCH
PAY ATTENTION.
IT IS INTERESTING, SENTENCING
GUIDELINES FOR FEDERAL CRIMES
ARE DUE FOR SOME REVISION.
THE PRESIDENT IS WILLING TO LOOK
AT THAT AND THE DEMOCRATS
ACTUALLY APPLAUDED THAT LINE IN
THE STATE OF THE UNION BUT WHEN
IT COMES TO ROGER STONE THEY
WANT THE FULL SENTENCE.
WAIT UNTIL THEY FREAK OUT WHEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP PARDONS HIM HERE
THAT WILL BE THE THE BIG WIN.
>> Juan: BUT WHAT DO YOU
THINK?
THIS IS A GUY WHO IS WITNESS
TAMPERING, OBSTRUCTING JUSTICE,
LYING.
>> Katie: THE GUY IN THE TRIAL
SAID THAT IT WAS ACTUALLY A JOKE
AND WE TALK ABOUT STUFF LIKE
THAT ALL THE TIME.
>> Jesse: HOAX INVESTIGATION